What is the significance of the
real date on Sanchez letter?
One wonders,
uh,
I don't have a ready answer for it,
but remember that it does have the
real date. It is obviously the date.
Once advantage is writing
this part of the [inaudible],
it may be a way of emphasizing, uh, the,
the novel is dealing with current,
uh,
history and situating the novel
chronologically in a specific way.
Uh, this is why, uh, the
letter a is given a date.
It didn't have to have a date,
but I think that that is the reason why,
uh, I think, I think that's the best
answer that I can give to the, uh,
to the question of why that letter,
what the significance,
what that date on the letter and
what the significance of of it is.
Uh, but this is the sort of detail
that I want you to look for.
Remember, uh, my mantra
details, details, details,
literature is made of specific concrete
details nor have obstructions like
philosophy.
And this is why it is
important to remember to notice
details and to base your
interpretations on the details.
Now as we move closer to
the end of the Quixote,
I would like to make some general comments
and revisit some of the themes that I
have touched upon earlier as a way of
summing up our reading of this great
classic that we have been,
uh, uh, reading all semester.
In the last lecture I talked about the
increasing presence of Virgil and have is
an need and suggested that Cervantes
is hinting of the significant
responsibility that his
protagonist is assuming,
which is quite different from
that of the ancient hero,
but no less important
to conquer himself,
to come to grips and control his
madness and to assimilate the,
uh,
his new one realization of the vanity
of his dreams and the futility of his
quest.
His task is to bring himself to harmony
with the world in which he lives full of
imperfections and disappointments and
to assure and to assume a resigned
attitude towards it and prepare
for his impending death.
If at the beginning of the semester,
I caught it, Luke Arch George Lucas,
actually Hungarian critic to the effect
that the Quixote was the epic of a world
abandoned by God.
Don't be this epic task within the novel
is to cope with such a world to conquer
such a world. I said, wow,
his is a very modern
condition in that sense,
but not necessarily a despairing one.
This,
I think is what the novel shows as
the hero begins his return home.
And this is why I'm asking
you to try to finish it. Uh,
don't get hopeless. Change is
gradual. And it began with I think,
DCNS enchantment by Sanshou,
the shock of, uh, see, uh, these,
uh, peasant woman, uh, as routine now.
And it peaked I think during the,
the,
the dissent to the cave
of Montesinos us. We, uh,
as we mentioned, uh, I think that he will,
he will display or he is displaying
now a deepened kind of wisdom,
nowhere more memorably
than in the council.
He gives sanctuary and his,
uh,
as his squire is prepared to take
over the government of the island of
Barataria.
You remember that episode when Gnocchi
halted takes central aside and after
telling him not to gloat,
uh, about his great fortune,
but to thank God that this happened
to him without his really even,
even trying
evincing a somewhat,
a little bit of a Mb, uh,
we're all don Quixote here.
He takes him aside to give
him some, uh, some council.
Um,
this passage of the Kihatha is one
of the more anthologized once in the,
uh,
Spanish speaking world.
I know I'm a judge in Puerto Rico who
has these pages framed in gold in his
office and he shows him,
shows him proudly to anyone
who happens to be near, uh,
uh, they are wonderful, uh, uh, uh,
this wonderful advice that not be
haughty. It gives sanctuary, uh,
and,
uh,
there are obvious philosophical and
literary sources and don't be hopeless
wisdom. Um, and, uh,
uh,
there are also obvious critical
statements that referred to the current
situation in Spain and Pyre,
particularly the council regarding the
corruption of people in power and in
government. These are Barb's or
the situation, uh, the, at the,
at the, uh, Spanish in a bureaucracy.
Uh,
okay.
Donkey hottest, uh, advice, uh,
how bookish sources,
uh,
but they also sound deeply felt and
also as if they were a grounded in a
experience. This is the,
the, the knowledge of, uh,
a mature man and look,
the whole day is more than a mature man.
He's an old man by the
standards of the age. So, uh,
he is an imposition to
counsel Sandra who's younger.
And of course, uh, his squire,
uh,
the counterparts to Don Quixote's
wisdom are Sanchez proverbs,
uh,
which expressive folks who kind of
cuteness and knowledge of humankind.
Uh,
and that's what we have seen in
Saint Joe can spew proverbs, uh,
of the drop of a hat.
Proverbs,
proverbs have been taken to be the
accumulated wisdom of the ages,
stored in the common memory of mankind
and were of great interest to renaissance
thinkers,
uh,
renaissance thinkers who were keenly,
attracted by language and the
knowledge that it contained,
uh, on, uh, both, uh,
both as a system of communications that
is language has grammar and also for the
contents of,
uh,
the lore that it's stored
not only Latin and Greek,
the classics as the human is
we're interested in, of course,
as we know in the classics and
in Latin and Greek and Hebrew.
But, uh, also in, in the
vernacular languages that were, uh,
in which they were immersed.
They were very, very interested
in that. And in fact,
uh, there is a whole science
of the study of proverbs, uh,
whose name
is in Spanish.
I don't know if the
word exists in English,
but a mural here.
They study of proverbs.
Uh, there seem to be many more
in Spanish than in English.
Anyway. Uh, I, I feel that way,
but probably because Spanish
is my native language.
But I remember a summer nights at the,
uh,
squaring Salamanca Beautiful Town
Square in Salamanca sitting around with
professors of language and see
who could say more proverbs.
And then also we invented the game
that one would say the first part of a
proverb and another would the second part
of another one that had nothing to do
with it. So it was a, it
was a really, uh, great, uh,
game of proverbs. Um, try it.
It's fun. So, uh, what I'm saying is
that provers are very much a part of the,
of their language and they are a kind of
a store house of wisdom and this is the
counterpart of donkey is more bookish,
uh,
uh, kind of, of knowledge. The
interest in grammar of course was that,
that,
uh,
it was thought that grammar and rec and
rhetoric could reveal the very workings
of the human mind. And this is where
human is. We're interested in it.
Um,
so now in the end sanctuaries,
wisdom is not going to be different from
that of Don Quixote and it is certainly
not inferior and in practice
proves to be quite effective.
Of course, Don Quixote's, uh,
advice extends to Sanchez, uh,
appearance,
more of dress to clip his
fingernails and to what,
what,
where on different occasions,
how to have his wife behave so that you
won't show that she's just depressant
and all of that. That is the
funny part of the, of the advice.
But Saint Joe's knowledge,
Santos wisdom is up to the, uh,
to the task.
Um,
Sanchez acumen is sufficient for him to
deal with the challenges of government
as it is for him to face the
challenges of his own life.
Sanctuary is endowed with natural reason.
This is a medieval concept that I have
mentioned before that courses through the
renaissance and reaches the enlightenment
where it will be instrumental in the
elaboration of modern
ideas about democracy.
Ideas that we all share, uh, today. Uh,
it is ultimately,
as I have said several times a common
Christian doctrine that we are all endowed
by God with enough intelligence,
uh,
to make it in the world no matter
what our station in life or level of
education. But at the end of
the episode on successful,
through no fault of his
own sanctuary ruse that he,
that he was not born to be a governor.
He says he accepts the social order,
which was based in spite of what I've
just said about natural reason was based
strictly on the ideology that a personal
social station was determined by God
and that it was best or central says
to stick to what you are and who the
conditioning to which you were
born. Uh, this is, uh, uh,
a conflictive a moment in
the, in, in, in the novel.
Uh,
but the fact is that he has done very
well as governor and only the deceptions
of the Duke and his minions rob
him of his real achievements,
real achievements in this fictional
world and what she accomplished them.
We both remember now, uh,
in connection to this,
remember our box theory about the birth
of realism on the Sediment Millie's that
is the, the common, uh,
discourse, uh, of Christianity.
So it can see that all of this
is, uh, is, is, is, is connected.
Uh,
but the contradiction of course,
he said within the society
which society that is crumbling.
As I have been saying, uh, this
distinctions is social distinctions are,
are important. They're
crumbling. Because look,
the most clever fellow in
this whole episode is the,
is this toward who after all is
a servant and sanctuary dose?
Uh, very well as a governor,
I said, governor, so, uh,
this is the overall theme of today's
class has to be that, that this, uh,
the social structures, uh, are crumbling
now. Uh, the, so we moved
to the island of Barataria.
Let us begin with, uh,
by talking about the name
in the, uh, in the original sanctuary.
First to the island
in Sula.
Let me put it with this first
more so you can see the accident.
Okay.
W and lowercase in Sula.
Now, of course, by this time,
the word for Ireland in Spanish was
already the current word, which is
from the Latin and the Latin. When
you had, uh, two consonants like that,
the tendency in the romance languages was
for the second one to absorb the first
one. So the therefore from insulin you
get east La, and in French you get Ila.
Now that's a little bit of philology.
Uh,
so Sangio repeats in Sula, uh, oh,
nowhere that it is an a
cake word than for island.
That donkey day uses
because he has learned it.
Reading the Romances of Chivalrous,
something that you lose completely in
the translation is the fact that donkey
hot day,
whenever the issue of
chivalrous arises or of Deucey,
Neha lapses into a kind
of our cake Spanish.
This is not,
this is not done in the translation.
Meaning he will say,
uh,
oh,
for instance,
fairly Moza for Eric Moser.
Yes.
Which is the,
uh,
west by then already the current
Spanish word for beautiful
it a Mossad. Did you want a little
more energy comes from the Latin,
from Pharma for Masa shapely.
Totally.
How the island of Formosa,
uh,
technology is fascinating.
Uh, so we're never know.
Quixote talks about you Roderick things.
He,
uh,
he uses far bladder for a bladder
because by the 16th century,
the f the Latin, uh, had
become a h and a silent h.
Um,
so
Sandra uses in Sula,
uh,
as the one he wants to rule an insular
island and he's using this archaic word.
So in Sula Barataria because
of this usage in the Quixote,
the word insula has a
currency in Spanish nowadays,
even if famous journal in Madrid,
a Insula,
uh, after, uh, this archaic word
uses we use by Don Quixote on Santo.
No
Barataria
I can never find the Harris
but artadia comes from Barato
but alto
means cheap.
So this will be cheap island.
She piled on cheap island both
because of its low cost and he's,
and it's shoddy, fragile,
fragile construction.
It is like a stage set to perform the
play that the Stuart has prepared.
It is cheap. Then also in the
sense that the island is not real.
I think that a better translation if we
were going to translate everything will
be something like Chins. The island
would be the name of it. Of course,
Sandra has Sanjaya does not pierce through
the name to realize that this is not
a very uh, uh, promising name for his,
for his kingdom to have to be ruling
cheap island. He doesn't know exactly.
He doesn't know at all what,
what means, but that's it.
This is what, what it means.
But our body
now let us begin by pointing out the
sources of the Stuarts invention.
The practice of making someone king
for the day was common in carnival
celebrations throughout Europe since
the Middle Ages and further back to
[inaudible].
Uh,
the joke that he's,
the humor was in seeing how a low class
dolt would act out his role as a king
or to have someone play the role of,
uh,
someone from the lower classes
trying to act like a king.
They could also be just a skit.
But part of the carnival practice,
uh,
was to make somebody a king for the day.
Uh,
this involved in this [inaudible] and
this kind of carnivals and inversion of
roles. We have echoes
of that, uh, in, uh, in,
in today's secret societies here in,
uh,
fraternities when they have
that day where, where the, the,
the pledges are in charge of the brothers.
All of those things that I'm sure you
have heard about our atavistic retention.
So this carnival type, uh, uh,
of ritual where you make
someone a king for a day.
In fact,
in the 1950s,
there was a TV show
called Queen for a day.
I don't know if you've ever heard of it,
uh,
in which a common housewife was
crowned queen for the day in the show.
And she got to to rule over people.
And two a and two have anything
she wanted and and, and so forth.
Um, yeah, television incorporated,
some of this, um, carnivalesque,
uh,
practices.
Now the practice extends to other cultures
beyond the western tradition besides,
uh,
the practice of making a stranger king
and then deposing him is one so prevalent
that Sir James Frazier,
I've mentioned him before,
but you've got to remember his
name, Sir James Fraser, f, r, a.
V. E. R, a devoted,
uh, many pages of his
classic, the Golden Bough,
uh, to this, uh, to this practice.
The idea was to punish the ruler for the
perquisites that he enjoyed wellbeing
king and for not having been able to
solve problems such as droughts and other
natural catastrophes.
We'll see this later when I quote Freud.
So they're stored is basing his
elaborate prank on a traditional routine.
Though he does take it
to an extreme.
This is not just king for a day,
but for several days. And, uh,
I said it and it's consistent in this
expansion and this exaggeration with the
baroque character of part two.
The point is that the whole thing
is supposed to be a joke, uh,
Santos expense and it is
part of the merriment,
the Duke and Duchess Palace.
It is also a part of the Marymount for
the participants in this whole charade.
They are acting it out as if,
as if this were a carnival.
Uh, there are other, uh,
traditional elements in the,
uh,
in the episode traditional, uh, um, act.
They should all scenes, uh,
for instance, the wanting,
which sancocho passes judgment on
several cases that come up before him.
Uh, he said traditional one
that goes back even to the Bible
console him on me. And, uh,
and also in folk traditions,
the traditions of riddles that
rulers or wise men are supposed to,
uh, to solve. Uh, the
tradition of Oracle's,
uh, back to the Greek, uh,
cause the Greeks unsold Sanko
solves several complicated cases.
Every single one of them
coming from folk tradition. Uh,
but hilarious at the same time I
bought Berkeley probably because of it.
They are hilarious. Uh, for instance,
central solves and kick a case
involving an alleged rape.
This is a very funny episode where the,
the,
uh,
the man is accused of
having raped this woman. Uh,
the man furthermore is
the lowest of the lowest.
So presumably this is, these are
all people acting out. He's a,
he's a hog herder pig keeper.
I mean,
this is the lowest I remember
in the first part when the,
the keeper of pigs arrives and,
uh,
even dimension of the word
Wetico in Spanish, uh, has
to be followed by, excuse me,
work for pig.
Uh,
and he's supposed to have forced
himself on this, uh, on this woman.
Uh, and, uh, uh,
on Santo has to decide
on, he has, remember this,
he asked, uh, the, the man
gave her a bag of money and,
and uh, when she's leaving,
he, let's take it from her.
And she fights like, like, uh,
an animal. So it was not to give up
the money. And then he says, well,
if you had defended yourself that
it would have been no, no rate.
But this is a case, remember,
uh, that I mentioned this in,
Eh,
when I talked about the,
uh,
the prisoner of sex is a case of
four Nicasio simplex case of simple
fornication. Uh, the, uh,
inquisition and Spanish law
had classified fornication,
the inquisition in its laws and all
that followed the scholastic practice of
classifications. Very, are you
still, are you still telic?
So there was simple fornication and then
qualified fornication of which there
were several kinds depending on
where the simple fornication is, is,
is sex between two people who are
on married and have different sex.
And then complex,
complex fornication comes when the people
are of the same sex. One is married,
uh, that both are married, but to other
people and so forth. That's the, yeah.
So this is a case of 40 of simplex. That
sanctuary, the judge is passing, uh,
uh, his, uh, sentence, uh,
on it. It is one of the, uh,
uh, traditional stories now.
Then he has to,
he's presented with a
very complicated case, uh,
about, uh, glad up. Better Lady now,
Clara Clear Pedal Edema derived
from peril, clear peril.
She's quite apparel.
Remember, this is the,
this is a young woman presumably in
this completely made up story within the
made up story. You know, the usual
receiving sequence instead of Lantis, uh,
who is half beautiful and have horrible.
And if you turn to your
page, uh, seven 69,
uh,
I say then the country man that this
son of mine who is to be the bachelor of
fell in love in the same village with
a downsell called Collada [inaudible]
daughter of our breast Pellegrino,
a very rich farmer and his name of
parallel going on these name of Pellegrino
game. Not to them by lineal or any of
the descent, but because of that race,
all of that race are subject to
the policy. And two men, the name,
they call them parallel Ryans
though to say the truth,
the downsell is luck.
Any oriental a peril and looked at on
the right side seams the very flower of
the field.
But on the left you start quite so fair
for on that side. She wants an eye,
which she lost by the small pox.
And though the pits in her face are many
on deep admirer, say they are not pits,
but sid packers, we're in the
hearts of her lovers are buried.
She is so clean that to
prevent the filing her face,
she carries her nose so crooked up.
But it seems to be flying from her mouth.
And for all that she looks extremely
well for. She has a large mouth and did.
And did she not lock half a score or a
docent and did she not like half a score
or a dozen teeth and grinders,
she might pass and make a figure
among ladies of the best fashion.
I say nothing of her lips and so on.
Uh,
central sees through all of this as
something made up, uh, and refuses to, uh,
for grantees.
But this is a very interesting figure
because I've mentioned in the last class
the figure of the monster who's made
up of contrasting features of opposing
features. In the case of three folding,
it was the black robe on the Hawaii,
a beard,
black and white.
And here it is extreme beauty
on one half and on the other,
this horrendous, uh, face for puck mark
and lacking and I, and all of that.
The, the two very opposites
clashing in one a figure.
This is in reference to the, this
Baroque, uh, the brokenness of part two,
but also to show, uh,
Saint Josephs, uh, uh,
sharp wit to see through, uh, this, uh,
Prac that they're trying to play on
him within the prank that he is already
undergoing.
If you compare Clara to Murray Torres,
you see that Marie Darnell's
is not that symmetrical,
but it our will all be from the top down.
Uh,
and uh,
whereas here we have a perfect,
a perfect symmetry. I
said, I have the door.
Now you have to remember always,
um, uh, keep insisting on the,
this is all made up by the Stewart who
is the author of this whole charade.
Now they just have the episode
is given by the story himself.
When he says in page seven, 90, 80,
81, I think, uh, uh,
(790) 801-0780 eight, 81, uh,
seven 80,
81,
when he says my Lord Governors scores the
Stuart speaks so well that I wanted to
hear a man. So void of learning as
your worship who I believe cannot,
not so much as read,
say such and so many things and all
sorts and tensions and instructive and so
far beyond all that could be expected
from your worships former understanding by
those who sent us and by
us who are come hitter.
But everyday producers,
new things just turn into Ernest
and jokers are joked upon.
Uh,
it is good to remember here and
I'm going to repeat a quote from a,
that American is Ruth Elsa far.
That is very appropriate, uh,
to uh, uh, at this point.
And I'll repeat it. She,
she wrote all of part two is based on the
mistaken assumption on the part of the
would be all controlling character authors
that they can deal with the fictional
character.
I maintain at the same time a distance,
which allows them never to slip into
that fictional world with which they plan
to entertain themselves. Luxon zone.
They are trapped from two directions.
They are controlled to some extent from
within their play by the very characters
whom they intend to
manipulate and from without,
by an author of whom they are unaware,
but who's will and whose hand or uh,
that they do is contrived.
And this is the case here of course,
of the steward who is himself
acknowledging that the, uh,
things have turned out,
uh,
not quite the way that he had planned
that he and the Duke and Duchess had had
planted, which was of course to have
a fun at the expense of central.
But central turns out on the
contrary, uh, to be, uh, quite a good,
uh,
governor and so that
they will start turned.
This is another one of this inversions
that are happening regularly in part two
of the, uh, of the Quixote, uh,
is also good to notice that,
uh,
the story is aware of,
uh, of both of his, uh,
construction of this whole episode
and have, it's a sort of collapse
now in a larger sense.
Uh,
Barataria has to do with the
breakdown of Aristocratic Authority
and the emergence of the common
man as a potential ruler.
Sankyo proves to be wise
beyond all expectations and
in spite of all the pranks,
uh,
that he and his master
endure as we've Globulin you.
The episode that we discussed in the last
class is dignity remains untouched and
the markers are the ones who are,
who are marked central
became a good governor.
This is the ironic result.
It counter intuitive resolution
that towards the designs
of the Duke and Duchess
and that under minds the authorial
intentions of the steward who obviously
wanted sanctuary to provide
the humor but acting stupid.
And,
uh,
this is in part, and this is something
that I had not mentioned before,
but uh,
that uh,
is easy to figure out this or miss
readings of part one on the part of
characters in part two,
they assume that the characters are
going act in a certain way by the way.
They have interpreted part one and they
have interpreted part one with Sandra as
a buffoon. Saint Joe's,
Joe's a comic character, uh,
which is the way by that Avi
Geneva interpreted a Saint Joe's.
We uh, if we remember the
class whenever you Neda, uh,
so it's good to keep this in
mind that these are miss reading.
So on the part of the Stewart on the
part of the Duke and Duchess who expect
though Quixote on Saint Jo to act
in a certain way. So these are, uh,
mistakes, uh, in the reading.
Uh,
no,
besides the folkloric sources
that I have mentioned of Barbaria,
uh,
the background is also a
literary and philosophical.
Uh,
it is a self contained society
presumably to be well run.
This is the humanistic theme of Utopia.
Going back to Thomas Moore.
You remember,
I have been mentioning all along
the names of important renaissance,
uh, figures, uh, that, uh,
but you must, uh, that
you should remember,
uh,
for, is it easy for you?
We just check it out.
And your Wikipedia,
uh,
more was the author of Utopia,
the book of the same name,
which was published in 15,
16.
Also Tommaso come Banella
come Panella, uh, 1568,
1639 who published a
city of the sun in 1602,
which was also a utopia.
Okay.
This is the idea that a perfect society
can be established on this earth
following a rational design.
The concept goes back,
of course,
to Plato's republic and to all the
treaties is that begin to appear in the
renaissance about the art of government,
including of course,
Machiavelli's the prince that I
have mentioned several times here.
This,
the prince is salts in the background
here because sanctuary is trying to act
like the perfect prince,
like the perfect ruler,
and hence Machiavelli's the prince
is in the background of this episode.
So see how many important,
uh,
renaissance thinkers are behind, uh, uh,
this in this episode. But
what does it mean? I mean,
you taught this week, you should
teach your doctors, by the way,
are the origin of modern political
systems or the idea that that with the
political system you can create or improve
a society to America like a utopia is
in the 18th century where particularly
this is ideas will become a reality.
And they have become, of course, as we
know, nightmares in the 20th century.
Some of these utopias of turned
out to be quite the opposite,
uh, to the point that you've had
to have walls to keep the, uh,
the people inside of them.
But so this is the idea, uh,
that you can rationally
create a perfect society.
Uh,
and uh,
so what is it here in this
episode of the Quixote?
Is it a parody of this,
uh, notions of Utopia?
I mean, but at Aria is a
mark utopia, of course,
with a fake king and all is being,
uh, an all it all ends in a,
in a, in a great catastrophe. Uh,
is it,
is it a parody showing the
futility of such attempts,
but it could be,
I think that the episode is important
enough and given enough relevance in the
book to invite
interpretations of this kind
now.
Yeah. Being an island reflects other
things. Three of them. For instance,
one of the idea,
one,
the idea of self containment and self
sufficiency of roundness as it were.
And at one point it is referred to us
[inaudible] round the island is round and
islands tend to be self contained
because of course they're surrounded by,
by water.
Uh,
to I think about that also reflects
the recently discovered islands of the
Caribbean recently, you
know, a late 15th century,
early 16th century where the Spaniards,
uh,
attempted to create societies
almost from the ground up,
uh, in the, in Hispaniola, uh,
in Cuba.
Uh,
and also the wished for,
but never reached islands of
the classical tradition. This,
this word called,
okay,
I'm going to put it in
English and the islands
and the,
okay.
This way you get the name for until the,
until it's comes from those
before islands, islands,
these were fugitive violence.
There's islands that you
saw in the distance and you
were supposed to arrive at
and they, uh, like the oasis in the
desert as you came closer, they,
they get,
they got further and further away.
But suggesting that this were Ireland
said you wanted to reach on that where
perhaps you would find utopia
or an oasis or something.
Of course,
when this level,
the island has the quality of elusiveness
that one would associate with Atlantis.
So you can see,
uh,
the depth of this episode
and Becky Hilty, uh, by, by,
by,
by dint of the many sources,
ideas and books that it has behind it.
Now,
Freud mentions this episode
in totem and taboo and he's,
he's taken this episode
is very instructive.
Now remember I mentioned I think in an
earlier class that Freud was a devoted
reader of Cervantes. And that as a, as
an adolescent, he created a servant,
this club with several friends to read
Cervantes and discuss it and so forth.
And they even give themselves names
from characters in sort of some of the
exemplary stories and all of that.
Now,
as you can see, as you will see, uh,
Freud interprets this episode,
uh,
by you sort of reducing it
to his own system of course
thinkers thing. To do that
he examines fraud examiners
the suffering king,
the suffering a king get must undergo
to pay for his exalted position in the
traditions that I have already
mentioned in Frasier, remember to Freud,
this is played out chiefly
in the hilarious scene
where Santo is denied food.
Uh,
Freud is drawing an analogy between
certain neurosis and the behavior of
primitives,
focusing on the ambivalent attitude
towards kings and it's analogue in the
relationship with
children to their fathers.
Okay.
People to the king, children to
fathers. He says, I quote here,
the importance of a particular person.
It's extraordinarily heightened and his
omnipotence is raised to the improbable
in order to make it easier to attribute
to him the responsibility for everything
painful that happens to a patient.
Savages really do not act differently
towards their rulers when they ascribe to
them power over rain and shine,
wind and weather and then
the throne or killed them.
Because nature has disappointed their
expectation of a good hunt or a ripe
harvest. Of course you can see the of
the father, the Omnipod and father,
uh, on, on hence the, the, the,
all of the theories Freud had
about the oedipal, uh, uh,
complex and all that.
He goes on those also,
the taboo ceremonial of kings is
nominally an expression of the highest
veneration because their relationship
to the father is an ambiguous one of
veneration and hostility and
a means of guarding them.
Actually,
it is the punishment for their elevation,
the revenge which their
subjects take upon them,
the experiences which
Cervantes makes sense.
Japan central banks down
the girl was governor,
governor of his island have evidently
made him recognize this interpretation of
courtly ceremonial as
the only correct one.
It is very possible that this point
would be corroborated if we could induce
kings and rulers of today to express
themselves from the point here.
Freud is of course being ironic and we're
going to ask kings and rulers today if
they want to undergo this kind
of process. Of course. Uh,
then he goes on to make the,
uh, unavoidable comparison
with the Christian myth.
He goes, why? The emotional
attitude towards rulers,
it should contain such a strong
unconscious share of hostility is a very
interesting problem. We
have already referred to the
infant towel father complex.
We may add that an investigation of the
early history of kingship would bring
the decisive explanations.
Frasier sergers,
a freshman who I mentioned
has an impressive discussion
of the theory that the
first kings where strangers
who after a short rain,
we're destined to be
sacrifice at solemn festivals.
That's representatives of the DDT.
But Frazier himself does not
consider these facts all together.
Convincing Christian myths are said to
have been still influenced by the after
effects of this evolution of kings.
Okay. The idea of the laying of, of,
of Jesus Christ, King of
the Jews and so forth. Uh,
but you can see how these illuminates what
is going on with [inaudible] with, uh,
with central bank said how
Freud's take on this helpless,
understand better the mechanism,
the mechanisms.
Now this is part of the
traditional background. Uh,
but also of course, the, the,
the nightmare of finally getting what
you crave and not being able to quite get
your hands on it.
You know,
those wish fulfillment dreams
where you have that Kate core,
let's put it in those terms. I'm
not given an erotic twist, uh,
that pie or something that you,
that you want and that you're about
to get and you don't quite get. Uh,
but also the disappointment
of achieving, uh, things,
things are never quite that we
imagine or desired. I mean B,
but they say it's be careful what
you wish because you may get it.
And once you get it, it may turn out
to be not exactly what you expected.
And there is something of that here too.
This is,
this is the strong dissing Gagnon
element of these episodes, uh,
on this, uh, on this island. The,
the scene that's so fascinated.
Freud in which bear that
or rescue they are widow.
That's the name we might want to
also unpack. This is the doctor.
They're very funny doctor who
keeps saying, no, no, no, you
can't eat that. Oh No, no.
God, that's the worst you can eat. No,
no, no, no. You cannot eat that. Uh,
but bed
plus your man's hard heart.
This [inaudible] you're treating me hard.
You say in Spanish, uh, the I widow
come be a last name,
but aware of means omen
urban model are Wedo it bad omen
and he isn't [inaudible]
that's the name of the town who
comes from it. You know what I mean?
Is like keep you out is what it means.
Keep you out.
When I was a kid and you
wanted to get rid of this kid,
an adult will tell him,
go see so and so and ask her
to give you some 10 tier. Yeah.
Keep you there. Uh, don't have to give
you some 10. Yeah. Keep you there.
So [inaudible] is more or less like a,
like that this is quite a remarkable
character. This, that this doctor, uh,
this is a very more yeah, like seeing
if you read them all. Yeah. In Malia,
there is always this a
hilarious criticism of doctors.
We're always toying
around with a huge animal,
trying to give an enema
to somebody. And, uh,
that sort of thing or whenever the
situation is, uh, is difficult,
they begin declining Latin, uh,
nouns and verbs because of course,
the idea is to know Latin well, to be able
to read the sources of, uh, uh, because,
uh, medicine was at this point, it's still
very scholastic based on all of this,
on sources, on written sources,
more than one experience,
some overdubs and experience.
See,
part of the Baroque is the clash between
this scholastic traditional knowledge
that does not stand up
to actual experience.
And this is why the critique of medicine
is so important and so relevant.
It's not just funny because it's
hilarious. It's very, very, very funny.
But it's also very significant because
it reflects a condition of the time.
Yeah,
no,
the n of Saint Joe's government,
he's got strong topic as you know.
Uh,
and there's one episode in which
like the fall from the horse, uh,
with the Foa of course explodes.
He may have been, uh, uh,
injured.
Um,
now Barataria is also lack a
laboratory experience on fiction
unfiction making.
How does one create a fictional
world coherent within itself?
All fictional novels or stories are
the creation of a coherent world within
itself. Uh, one that is round as it were,
the fiction, uh, obviously gets
out of hand of the steward.
He cannot quite stand outside
of it. Uh, uh, like a puppeteer.
And this is parallels to,
to master pier on his puppet show.
Uh,
and perfection of course,
of this
fictional world cannot
be, uh, quite achieved.
And this is parallels to, of course
Sylvana situation. Vis-A-Vie uh, the,
uh, Nicky Haughty, uh, one way
that I imagine it is, I mean,
if this is the world of fiction,
the Creator,
uh,
the story is here trying to control it,
but he winds up here
and once he is inside,
he does not have the all encompassing
perspective and he has all of the problems
that the characters he has created have.
So that is the,
the this or the irony comes in and
this is where, uh, we're, we're bought,
on the other hand,
this effort to create this self contained,
coherent fiction anticipates what Macondo
the fictional village in 100 years of
solitude.
Komala the fictional village
in blue for Pedro Paramo.
If you're not aware of this,
uh,
room for one room for
the great Mexican writer
and he's normal that I read it all.
Sell from the idea of you talked yet to
also to the idea of creating a fictional
world. You see, the connection
is all behind the island of, uh,
of party Barataria. Now, uh,
we are going to talk, uh, next, uh,
in the next class about LTC Laura,
this mark Ddo Dido that I hope
you, uh, uh, you are reading,
uh,
and also about doing your Rodriguez.
This is the one whose daughter
is impregnated and whose,
uh,
whose boyfriend refuses to marry her and
they don't put pressure on him because
he's the son of the person who lends
money to the Duke and Duchess. Uh,
this is that she's a very
interesting character.
She's the one who reveals the physical
defects of the Dutcher's unwell,
Dizzy Dora. What are the physical
defects of this women? Uh,
the Dodgers are sort of the beautiful
hunters and all of that apparently has
some sores in her legs that, uh, that, uh,
which some liquid flows.
As you see,
Laura has bad breath.
This is beautiful, LTC Laura who
sings, I don't know that, uh,
during your Rodriguez with great,
uh, resentments actually has
a consol, the tired
breath. Uh, so she has a,
these are defects that we're not going to,
we would not have found in the
idealize women of part one and a.
So this is significant
about, uh, about, uh,
[inaudible] Rodriguez and the
things that Ge, uh, Ge, uh, reveals.
But I want to finish by,
uh,
by talking about Don Quixote and sank
to the pair because I came across two
recent articles on the two of them as a
pair that I want to sort of summarize,
uh, for you. One is by Antonio
carrying your Rodriguez.
I emphasize the RS and
the [inaudible] and Tonio.
Okay.
Um, I'm [inaudible] talks
about the influence of okay.
Hotel on St Joe on modern modern comedy
pairs a switch as Abbott and Costello,
Oliver and hardy
on even takes it all the way
up to characters in Seinfeld.
Uh, uh, a a a show.
God, I have to confess,
I have never in my life seen.
Uh,
but he has a picture here, uh, uh,
of characters from that,
uh,
the show not apparently show a,
a decided influenced from
a Doki haughty and San Jo.
He also gives the folkloric background
of this pairs going back to the Middle
Ages and projected projected then
forward on to the present. I mean,
I want to Costello, one is fat.
Uh, the straight man who, uh,
and then the, the, uh, you
can see immediately the
moment I mentioned that, yes,
this is don Quixote and sanctuary
in, in, in, in, in film.
The other, uh, it's an article
by my friend Edwin Williamson,
who's a distinguished Oxford Hispanic,
and it has to do with what it turns
the power struggle between luxury hotel
sanctuary,
which is resolved ultimately in favor of
the squire because Don Quixote's having
to beg him to please let us give himself
the lashes necessary to disenchant Lucy.
Now he mentions four episodes,
the fooling hammers or no
Quixote hits him over the head.
Uh, and, uh, the enchanted
[inaudible], Neha,
when there is an inversion of,
of roles and a sanctuary is
now the one creating the,
uh, evaluate, uh,
kind of reality out of a
normal everyday, uh, alive,
uh,
Merlin's prophecy when he states that
it is Sandra who must give himself the
lashes on his behind
to disenchant Lucy now,
which then makes donkey
hotter dependent on sandwich.
Uh, and, and finally a chapter that you,
uh, an episode you may not
have read yet in chapters 60.
The fight between the two of them when
a donkey hot Quixote tries to force
central to give himself lashes
and two takes his clothes off to,
to give him the lashes.
And Central wrestles don Quixote to the
ground and puts his knee on his chest
and says he will not do that.
Uh,
Williamson gives an appropriately, uh, uh,
political reading to this a
power struggle. Uh, and, uh,
which,
which I agree.
I think that he's a unduly
harsh about the end when he,
he sees that sanctuary is being totally
cynical, even a donkey halters deathbed.
I think that that Williams from
when a little bit too far there,
but I want to in conclusion today to read
you read you his conclusion because it
is very much in tune with what I have
been saying about Barataria and the rice
of the common man to a position of uh,
government Cervantes.
Moreover says Williamson was not aware
of the wider political dimension of the
power struggle that he had first Adam
braided as far back as a fooling mills
filling hammers episode in part one in
the final crisis when the night has been
forced to the ground by his
squire Sanchez defiant assertion.
Are you domain Ami [inaudible] me Sr.
I helped myself because I have my own
master inevitably carries political
resonances for eating plies,
a conscious rejection of the traditional
basis of authority and status and
portents the emergence of a different
world or world that's Advantis himself
must have imagined with this
quiet if not with dread,
those at the heart of the Quixote.
There is an intriguing irony.
Instead of one test may well have started
out on his adventure of writing with
the purely literary aim of discrediting
the Makena malformed dollar of that.
You've all read romances,
but by a series of logical steps arising
from the interaction of master and
servant, he was led to undermine
the principle of hierarchy.
That was the cornerstone
of the ideology of his day.
We would continue with this and
other themes in that next class.